economía en directo América de France 24
Daniela Blandón con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela vamos a hablar de la
industria mundial de vehículos porque
las marcas siguen experimentando
retrasos en las entregas y las
proyecciones no son nada alentadoras Qué
tal Raúl Pues esta persistente escasez
mundial de semiconductores continúa
obstaculizando los esfuerzos de los
grandes fabricantes de automóviles del
mundo para superar los problemas de
suministro que ya venían de la pandemia
Como por ejemplo Toyota que es la mayor
firma Automotriz del mundo por volumen
de ventas reconoció el viernes que es
muy probable que no cumpla con su meta
de producción en de 9,7 millones de
vehículos en el presente año fiscal que
inició en abril y que va hasta marzo de
2023 pero es una situación que comparte
toda la industria como nos lo explica
Eduardo Bisbal Rey el ese vicepresidente
de comercio exterior de la federación
nacional de comerciantes de Colombia
los vehículos tienen unos componentes
muy importantes de carácter tecnológico
son sensores y una serie de cosas en los
cuales pues no pueden operar
esta producción se ha
por razón por digamos por informaciones
que he tenido los
proveedores de estos
ascensores Y estos artículos
electrónicos están prefiriendo venderlos
a la fábrica de productos de teléfonos
celulares y de artículos de altas
tecnologías que dándole prioridad a
ellos seguramente por razones económicas
de todo caso pues esto a dificultado el
suministro de vehículos en el mundo no
solo en Colombia
y ya estoy que adicionarle en los
problemas con el transporte marítimo con
Pues los puertos más grandes del mundo
como son los chinos
pues han estado cerrados y
con muchas dificultades entonces antes
de la pandemia muchos contenedores es un
pasivos hubo que dejarlos en x Oye he
puesto y no ha habido la forma de poder
regresar por ellos y normalizar este
transporte
Daniela pero no solo es la escasez de
semiconductores No señor también hay
escasez de materias primas y muchas de
ellas lo hacen por la guerra en Ucrania
el vicepresidente financiero del Renault
por ejemplo aseguró el viernes que el
litio es el principal dolor de cabeza y
en ese sentido se espera un pico
significativo en los precios de las
materias primas en el segundo trimestre
también reconoció que el nivel de
inventario de sus concesionarios sigue
siendo muy bajo y que deberá trasladar
parte del aumento de esos costos a sus
clientes por supuesto el jefe de
producción de La alemana BMW prevé que
la estabilización de las cadenas de
suministro se produzca el próximo año y
El fabricante sueco de camiones sabe
Volvo también hizo hincapié en el
aumento de los precios de la energía que
ha elevado la presión financiera sobre
los proveedores a comienzos de este año
también El fabricante de autos de lujo
tesla preveía que se iba a subir un 50%
en ventas pero no lo va a cumplir como
varias de sus metas todo esto está
generando un nuevo fenómeno que se
podría resumir en el apetito por los
vehículos usados antes de la pandemia
era común que un auto bajara de precio
con solo salir del concesionario hoy la
tendencia es totalmente contraria
la dificultad de abastecer de vehículos
nuevos Pues que los usados sean
valorizados muchísimo Esto no se daba en
Colombia desde la época en que solo
había ensambles
para darles una idea
en la época pre pandemia antes de 2019
un por cada vehículo nuevo que se
entraba al mercado
movían tres usados en la cadena hoy se
están moviendo entre 7 y 8 usados en la
casecena en la cadena por cada nuevo que
entra de tal manera que
si el vehículo usado Pues estamos viendo
y ha generado una dinámica especial
producto de las dificultades del
abastecimiento de vehículos nuevos al
mercado
bueno Daniel ante esta situación en la
decide Muchísimas gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica ya
sabe que no es un buen momento para
comprar vehículo nuevo no es un buen
momento así que pues tengamos nuestros
carritos a lo mejor puede seguir
aumentando quién sabe Daniela como
siempre Muchísimas gracias